>> President Trump: THE
GOVERNOR OF OHIO IS DOING A
GREAT JOB.
HE CALLED IT OFF AND WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
IT HASN’T FULLY BEEN DETERMINED
YET.
IF HE CALLED IT OFF, I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE HE IS
DEFINITELY SOMEBODY THAT KNOWS
WHAT HE’S DOING.
WE WILL BE SEEING WHAT A VERY
SOON.
>> Neil: THAT IS FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE
SAYING THE SAME THING ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR.
THE POLLING LOCATIONS AFTER
GOVERNOR MIKE DeWINE POSTPONE
ELECTIONS TODAY.
THE SUPREME COURT BACKING THE
GOVERNORS DECISION.
IT GOVERNOR MIKE DeWINE,
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
>> HAPPY ST. PATRICK’S DAY.
>> Neil: TO YOU AS WELL.
SOME PEOPLE SAY, THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO THIS?
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS SEEM
TO BE PACKING YOUR MOVE.
WHY DID YOU PUT IT OFF?
>> WE DID NOT WANT TO PUT
OHIOANS AT RISK.
WE HAVE 5,000 POLL WORKERS THAT
IT TAKES TO PUT ON AN ELECTION.
I’M SURE OUR VIEWERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
THEY ARE WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
SOME HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
LONG, LONG TIME.
SOME ARE OLDER MORE AT-RISK
INDIVIDUALS.
SO THIS IS A DISEASE.
THIS IS A VIRUS THAT SOMETIMES
PEOPLE CAN’T TELL THAT THEY HAVE
IT.
THEY COULD BE A SPREADER WITHOUT
KNOWING THAT.
HAVING THEM WORK FOR 13 STRAIGHT
HOURS JUST MADE NO SENSE.
IT’S ALSO A RISK TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE VOTING.
THE REGULATIONS THE DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY THAT SAID NO MORE THAN
50 PEOPLE IN A ROOM.
WE CERTAINLY COULD NOT CONDUCT
AN ELECTION THAT WAY.
AND FINALLY, WE DID NOT WANT TO
REALLY CHALLENGE OUR VOTERS,
PARTICULARLY OUR VOTERS THAT
HAVE A MEDICAL PROBLEM OR VOTERS
THAT ARE OVER 65 TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN EXERCISING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND THEIR
HEALTH.
THAT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
WE CAN DO IT.
WE CAN HAVE ABSENTEE BALANCE
THAT CAN GO ON FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME.
EVERYONE CAN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE THAT WANTS TO.
THAT’S REALLY WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
>> Neil: I WAS WONDERING THAT
ABOUT THE OTHER STATE SCHEDULING
PRIMARIES TODAY.
ARE THEY MAKING A MISTAKE?
>> LOOK, I WOULD NOT SAY THAT.
EVERY GOVERNOR DOES WHAT HE OR
SHE THINKS IS BEST FOR THEIR
STATE.
GOVERNORS ARE RIGHT THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THAT CALL.
I WOULD NOT CRITICIZE THAT CALL.
I MADE THIS CALL BECAUSE IT WAS
CLEAR THAT THIS WOULD PUT IN
JEOPARDY THE SAFETY OF OHIOANS.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM THIS FROM
THE MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
AND ALL THE EXPERT IN EVERY
DECISION WE HAVE MADE HAS BEEN
BASED ON MEDICAL SCIENCE.
BUT WE HAVE LEARNED IS THAT IF
YOU DON’T INTERVENE EARLY IN
THIS, YOU’LL END UP LIKE ITALY
IS TODAY.
THAT IS VERY, VERY TRAGIC.
WE HAD A HOLD MEETING TODAY
DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR HOSPITALS
GETTING READY FOR THIS.
WE WILL RUN OUT OF EQUIPMENT.
WE WILL RUN OUT OF PERSONAL
PROTECTION GEAR FOR THE DOCTORS
ON LAST SLOW THIS DOWN.
AND IT CAN’T BE THIS GO STRAIGHT
UP LIKE THEY HAVE HAD IN ITALY.
WE’VE GOT TO SHUT IT DOWN A
LITTLE BIT AND SPREAD IT OUT OR
WE WILL BE IN THE SAME POSITION
ITALY IS.
AND WE DON’T WANT TO BE THERE.
>> Neil: TO LIGHTEN THIS
ENTIRE VIRUS SITUATION.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID OF
YOU TODAY, SIR, THAT YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THIS WAS TYPICAL
OF YOUR NO-NONSENSE WAY IN WHICH
YOU DELIVERED A DAILY DOSE OF
BAD NEWS IS SAYING OF YOU THAT
YOU FREQUENTLY -- THE ADVICE OF
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
HE SHOWS THE IMPACT OF HIS
CHOICES WHICH HE HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED COULD BE
DEVASTATING FOR THE ECONOMY.
HE SUGARCOAT NOTHING.
I’M SURE POLITICAL ADVISORS HAD
TOLD YOU, GOVERNOR, WHEN YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THESE
TOUGH MEASURES -- AND YOU HAVE
BEEN TALKING LONG BEFORE THEY
HAVE BECOME A FASHIONABLE OR
COMMON.
YOU TOOK A LOT OF POLITICAL HEAT
FOR THAT, BUT SHE DIDN’T SEEM TO
CARE.
>> I THINK OHIOANS REALLY NEEDED
TO UNDERSTAND THE TRUTH.
IF I’M GOING TO HAVE ANY
CREDIBILITY, I NEED TO BE HONEST
WITH THEM.
I HAVE A GREAT DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH WHO IS LENDING ME THROUGH
THIS.
WE CONSULTED WITH EXPERTS NOT
ONLY IN OHIO, BUT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IS YOU GOT
TO MOVE EARLY.
THERE IS A CLASSIC CASE IN 1918
BETWEEN ST. LOUIS AND
PHILADELPHIA.
PHILADELPHIA IT WAS ONLY 2 WEEKS
BEHIND ST. LOUIS AND WHAT THEY
DID.
THE DEATH RATE IN PHILADELPHIA
WAS DRAMATICALLY HIGHER THAN IT
WAS IN ST. LOUIS.
>> Neil: PHILADELPHIA TOOK NO
PRECAUTIONS.
>> EVENTUALLY, THEY DID.
THEY HAD THE ST. PATRICK’S DAY
PARADE AND THEY WENT ON.
IT WAS TOO LATE.
THIS STUFF MULTIPLIES.
I’M TOLD BY THE EXPERT THAT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN OHIO AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN AFFECTED -- THAT
NUMBER WILL DOUBLE EVERY SIX
DAYS.
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS TODAY, IT
DOUBLES EVERY SIX DAYS.
THAT IS JUST CRAZY.
WE HAVE GOT TO SLOW IT DOWN AS
MUCH AS WE CAN.
>> Neil: THE FLIP SIDE OF A
NUMBER THAT CAN GROW
EXPONENTIALLY IS THE DENOMINATOR
CHANGES THINGS BEARD AND A
NUMBER OF THE THAT THESE IS LOWE
THAN WE THOUGHT.
AND SOME PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY, WELL, YOU KNOW, IT’S BETTER
STEPPING BACK FROM IT AND SEEING
THAT YOUR CHANCES OF DYING ARE
MUCH LOWER NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MOVE
QUICKLY.
WE KNOW THAT IF WE DON’T MOVE
QUICKLY, WE WILL SEE MORE PEOPLE
DIE.
THAT HAS BEEN THE EVIDENCE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
WE HAVE EXPERT MODELERS THAT
LOOK AT THAT.
THIS MAY MEAN THAT WE ARE IN IS
LONGER FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO -- THE OTHER
MAJOR PROBLEM THAT PEOPLE DON’T
REALLY TALK ABOUT OR LOOK AT IS,
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN OUR HOSPITALS
ARE OVERWHELMED?
WE HAVEN’T SLOW THIS THING DOWN,
AND YOU HAVE A HEART ATTACK OR
YOU HAVE NEEDS SURGERY OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED ADVERSELY AS WELL.
WE WORRY ABOUT THEM AS WELL AS
THE PEOPLE WHO CONTRACT THIS
VIRUS.
>> Neil: THE PRESIDENT SEEMED
TO INDICATE THAT THIS COULD BE
JULY OR AUGUST BEFORE IT HITS
ITS CEILING.
THERE IS NO WAY OF KNOWING.
THE PRESIDENT SAID AS MUCH.
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS INDICATED 45
DAYS BEFORE THE WORST OF IT IN
NEW YORK.
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY ARE
DIFFERING ON WHETHER THEY HAVE
MEASURES IN NEW YORK CITY.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT LEVEL
LEVEL?
EXTENDED TO NOT EVEN LEAVING
YOUR HOME MY PERIOD?
>> WE ARE NOT THERE YET IN OHIO.
WE COULD GET THERE.
WE ARE NOT THERE.
WHAT WE ARE DOING -- I’M GOING
TO DO IT AGAIN RIGHT NOW.
ALL OHIOANS, IF YOU CAN STAY
HOME, STAY HOME.
IF YOU CAN WORK FROM HOME,
PLEASE DO THAT.
FOR ANYBODY 65 YEARS OF AGE OR
OLDER, DO NOT HAVE CONTACT WITH
VERY MANY PEOPLE APPEAR TO JUST
TRY TO CONFINE THAT TO A VERY,
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
THE DEATH RATE GOES UP
DRAMATICALLY AS PEOPLE GET
OLDER.
IT’S NOT JUST WHAT ORDERS I MAKE
OR MY HEALTH DIRECTOR MAKES.
WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS HOW
EVERYONE TAKES CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE CARE OF
YOURSELF, YOU’RE TAKING CARE OF
YOUR FAMILY.
YOU’RE ALSO TAKING CARE OF TOTAL
STRANGERS.
KEEP THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE AWAY.
WE HAVE TO GO ABOUT OUR LIVES.
IF WE CAN, WE HAVE TO HUNKER
DOWN.
I KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE LITERALLY
IN THEIR HOME NOW AND DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN AND GO OUT
AND GET GROCERIES.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CANNOT TO EXPOSE THEMSELVES TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT’S THE WAY TO GET THROUGH
THIS.
>> Neil: YOU ARE RIGHT.
GOVERNOR, YOU ARE VERY CLEAR AND
VERY SOBER ABOUT IT.
DON’T MAKE A CRISIS OF IT.
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN OR